est-ce que tu as déjà pleuré devant
Bambi oui il est sympa bras pit oui tu
as déjà triché lors d'un examen oui
est-ce que un film de 3h30 c'est trop
long un peu tu es optimiste pour
l'avenir de la
planète c'est un rien je sens c'est plus
tu regardes tes propres films à la
télé non l'argent fait-il le bonheur non
les salles de cinéma est-ce que ça va
disparaître un jour non est-ce que tu as
le sentiment d'avoir réalisé tes rêves
oui jouer une grande méchante est ça
tenterait oui est-ce que Paris c'est
mieux que Bruxelles non est-ce que c'est
difficile d'aimer les enfants des
autres tu peux répondre que oui ou non
tu peux mettre un je pass sur
CCI dire non alors très bien est-ce que
ça t'arrive encore de passer des
castings je pourrais mais non est-ce que
les gens s'endorment vraiment au César
oui tu te vois faire du cinéma toute ta
vie à partir de maintenant oui est-ce
que tu pourrais jouer un rôle
intégralement en anglais
oui of course